[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys good to be here let's
Marnie gonna be I'm pretty good at
dating I love the ladies
I used to date this beautiful lady who
was really into yoga and choke sex I was
like do you drink breathing or not
remaining millennial
I'm hidden when the ladies call me a
premature ejaculator premature tanu I
came right at the perfect time when I
felt amazing makes maturity their
nominees yourselves I am single I have
yet to meet my soul mate
I mean I think maybe it's her fault she
needs a good album or she seems like a
loser
I think I can do better
my friends are like dude you don't want
how to talk to women maybe or maybe
women should learn how to listen to
Hannes
why don't you want to hear about the
Federal Reserve this one way was like
did you know that because I can make a
baby my vagina is technically a 3d
printer
I was like actually your womb is the 3d
protection your vagina is the train
there is one thing with lots of errors
these nine months the print and the
whole time is printing is complaining it
was to say I did not send each phrase I
love sexual intercourse
and about 9% of its next career with
solo and now I have an orgasm Wilson was
breathing on me
[Music]
the sex with a dude I've never looked at
a beautiful woman it been like she's
gorgeous but is there a version of her
that's bigger and hairier - my friends
are like - were so lucky we're not gay
can you imagine if most of the gender we
were attracted to was it attracted to
his back and I was like whoa can't even
imagine he was crying a lot
yes that lifestyle I mean I don't
understand what hope you have people
will be like it's Adam and Eve not Adam
and Steve but Anthony for not even a
good couple biblically first of all
disobeyed God and ate of fruit they
weren't supposed to eat which is tie
game
nothing raised Cain and Abel and Cain
murdered Abel why are you taking
parenting advice to people raise up
murderer they're only three other people
on earth [ __ ] together just killed up
half the genetic diversity on earth I am
Asian and agro Christian as an Asian
person which is kind of weird because
the people were at the Bible didn't seem
to know that ages existed they could
even drop us a line by inventing the
fireworks were really proud of you guys
the Jews my favorites thanks buddy
[ __ ] Jews
I don't hate the Jews I'm just saying
the Bible's a little jewy
I hope they throw Krish my sisters has a
WWJD bracelet what would Jesus do but I
very rarely see a Jewish carpenter build
a burn house speak Hebrew do something
most an agent woman she just got back
from a mission trip if you don't know
what a mission trip is that's what
Americans go to different countries to
get new profile pictures kind of like I
have a little Christian anymore I am an
atheist because I'm not a kindergarten
and have an internet connection
are they giving stressful to of an
ideology that could be destroyed by
facts the Bible of the good book but I
think old man the seat was better what
kind of book introduces the main
character two-thirds of the way through
the novel and then just kills them off
right away for today
the rest of the buggers are invited
banned all the things that are happening
in politics I am part of the entry game
game he's not down so I guess we're
never gonna get the limited yang
stirrers paradise I believe in the
universal basic income I don't
understand all these CEOs or like I was
most what about my employees if I can't
threaten them with homelessness you mean
if I want people to work for my company
I have to have a company people want to
work for what about the private health
care they do what we wanted we're gonna
so well before the real reason I believe
that everyone should get 1,000
everyone is because I think poor people
are disgusting I want to get rid of
every single one of ever given a lot of
money everyone's happy I you know I'm
very political it's just part of my
lifestyle I think being Asian is pretty
cool a lot of people are like immigrants
are awesome but they really don't talk
to immigrants you know
have you ever you know kind of word if
they're always like go clean your room
stop and read move out of my basement
okay mom that is your real name
I don't understand the people who want
everyone to speak English because
they're never the type of people that
want to have a conversation with a
foreigner like learn to speak English so
I can learn more about dwelling the
festival of lights'
language barriers killing me you want
everyone on this vest to be able to
speak English to you that's gross
you speak Hungarian it go over there I
don't want to say all the sayings in
English they say in prison don't drop
the soap just letting the helpful should
be don't pick up the soap
because your office had self as you
wanted the bending over where they
really get to so you're still gonna get
arranged I'm just gonna have really
clean handle it happens what is
prisoners like man I want to get that
kid but never drops us so like that
they're go getters didn't take no for an
answer so I do love rednecks
I think rednecks are pretty cool because
they can survive in any wilderness
situation that you put them in except a
situation where everyone has equal
rights [ __ ] enough you can live in a
swamp an alligator I can't live in a
cul-de-sac with a minority smiling I
don't understand people who say make
America great again because that means
they hate what we have now so they want
to go back to the past but if we go back
to the past we're just going to get this
again let's look Zack Tressa people this
thing you hate so much is what we did in
the past it's like being like I hate
this cake let's go back to the time we
mix the flour with the egg and put it
love it
it's a good case another king I of
course am NOT a racist I'm a minority
how could I be a possible I don't even
see race I only smell it I was actually
at an airport and I started reading a
book in Arabic which kind of freaked me
out but then it's not pull the corner of
the page put the book away and I was
like oh thank god he's got future plans
I have agent for the nuns country of
Chinese I'm from a Province in China
called South Korea thanks to Japan
prawns it's a great being agent because
whenever someone is racist to me I'm
like oh you made it respectful people
who keep to themselves okay good luck
finding an affordable car I have a South
Korean so I am a southerner
a lot because Koreans people you dogs
which I'm saying can be very shocking
because in America at Dollar Tree like
family members but in Asia we treat her
family members like family members this
way little tradition we have back belly
buying an animal we love my grandma one
of my agent friends make fun of me
they're like dude Hans you eat General
Tso's chicken
music Jensen's chicken just a shitty
Americanized version of something
authentically Asian and I'm like yeah so
my my favorite movie is rush hour 3
I love the Black Panther movie I thought
that was a great movie because it gave
black children and hero they could
finally look up to and not just someone
like Martin Luther King jr. or Malcolm X
or Harriet Tubman
Rosa Parks of Maya Angelou or partially
not desiccated said Joe Frazier the most
mentally no there's the big person that
first thing I can what are they going to
come out the yellow Panda Kung Fu Panda
does not count
Jack like it's hard to date as an Asian
man that both exist women are beautiful
that everyone thinks Asian men are
beautiful which doesn't even make any
sense because I think Asian women I've
created me [ __ ] I'm a crucial part of
the sex process please stop trying to
scare me give us excellently our
children are very beautiful regret
engineers and unfortunately Asian women
act like they're so much better than
Asian men back home with our your way
anyone can [ __ ] white dudes I think
having white pride is a good thing but I
think a lot of people do it incorrectly
they're always look like the Nazis of
the Confederate flag but never into
building a castle or you only
that's all white pride that's racism you
don't have to be white to be racist okay
I can get the juice too
I don't like it I did comedy at the
heart became disease I'm surrounded by
the race you know I don't understand the
Confederate flag that really not flying
would be like a man when it to his wife
and was like hey my from that time again
tonight huge argument I try to divorce
here for different of that time where
the represents Who I am as a person so I
got a divorce papers tattooed on my
chest so yeah I mean my name is Hans Kim
the beds were real babe my parents see
me Hans because if they're on two kids
at school to make fun of me for having
an Asian name so they gave me a German
one instead of the ran under the radar I
have a funny name but I think it's even
funnier that Tanner's a white person's
name and then what
should be like hey this is my Mexican
friend tanner
that's my black botanas America I think
carpool lanes are [ __ ] man yeah
carpool lanes is like society saying hey
you know how you're lonely yeah why
don't you do that for a little longer
than white people with friends whizzing
by you this must make friends I go too
fast
another big fan of crowds crowds really
make me nervous they're my least
favorite thing that's two individuals I
think it's probably that a lot of people
think that I'm pizza anime I know what I
look like but I'm not that at anime
which is unfortunate because the only
women who are sexually attracted to me
are prettier to animate the whole thing
I forgot a resting anime face I'm
constantly cosplay I'm go to a damn like
whoa
and Americans I think it's great that a
lot of people are patriotic I don't
think everyone is patriotic is dumb
but I don't think everyone who's dumb is
gonna be a little preacher up there you
got nothing great going out of your life
you're gonna be like well at least
something here I think capitalism is
great if you want to do it but don't
make everyone play your stupid game okay
I like fortnight I don't make a grandma
play and take away our house if she
loses when you're baking cookies
I like how Americans you say communism
never works as if we didn't spend
billions of dollars to kill millions of
people to make sure it wouldn't work
remember the war in Vietnam Bay of Pigs
animala Nicaragua we're pretty asians
about it now war against communism never
works because whatever people try that
they're democratically like the leaders
mysteriously dying
and plane crashes and the small rubber
group always with automatic weapons
whenever you try commies
why are you say bless yourself way to
stabilize you so for yourself
I'm not a communist but I do support any
policies that Republicans consider
communism which is whatever total people
gathered to do something nice I do you
think people who play Bluetooth speaker
music a lot in public have ever cross
paths with each other that's annoying
I like now we have extra security on
9/11 as the problem
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
how does that Elevens happen in
September I think I do but Tara's
slipping to the calendar
[Applause]